what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are back for bad batch season two
joined by my friend who you might have seen on
the Jedi Survivor trailer reaction with me one
of the biggest Star Wars nerds I know but easily
the only individual I know in real life who is
vehemently looking forward to the bad batch
Michael the Tesla how are you Michael oh I am
doing absolutely magical I'm so excited it's the
bad batch it never gets enough credit but it's
for those of us that love the Clone Wars I would
say Rebels too because it looks like I love Rebels
connective intermediate threat it's more than
animation style there's just like something about
it that like brings me back to being single and
alone in high school um it's a good feeling it's
just like oh well yeah I could I could try to go
out or I can enjoy the Star Wars content who needs
a girlfriend when you have Dave filoni like for
Dave filoni people come comment for Pablo Hidalgo
subscribe and click that notification Bell to get
notified when a reaction for the next batches up
also full length and watch along as we sync up
with your own copy of the bad batch available for
our super sexy Rejects at our patreon page we also
cover several shows over there exclusively with
reaction highlights and watch alongs included
Michael ready to get the show on the road um
I just wanted to hold my baby I like
to think of the bad batch as the real
rejects of the Star Wars Universe
let's get the show on the road
that starts off on Grievous yeah
I wonder what his corpse is doing at
this point I think he's still on YouTube
ah yeah
Spoils of War that's nice
the Metal Gear Solid episode
well this looks beautiful yeah right
tired of Life on Coruscant
what are those
Omega
it's a tad older yeah it's got
this whole Ezra thing going on
who is that we need a pickup copy that
we're on our way you're gonna kill all
these innocent creatures God it's very
jedi-like the women and the children
what a swashbuckling open up here right
oh Moana is way cooler than I remember she
is so much more badass yeah right foreign
how do you not love this show it's so much fun
it is a fun show Crowds Are like you something
some [__] staying inside the ship next
time I'll try but it was still pretty fun
yeah this is good it kind of feels like the jump
that Ezra had from season one
the season two Rebels quite late
they're still at the bar yeah where else to be the
space decided to finally show up better late than
dead I always say and who are you yeah who are you
wouldn't you like to know yeah I would actually so
this is the top team you've been
talking about it's like what is
yeah they let everybody in Star Wars
now huh she's a friend she's the most
trustworthy pirate I know because it's
supposed to be comforting aren't clone
supposed to look alike so much for
quality control it feels offensive
this one's got a face tattoo yeah real
subtle hey now got a name brown eyes oh
however the phenotypic eye color for all clones
is brown Iris pigmentation was not affected by
it was fascinating God damn technique just
when you had a chance blew it right away
then action follow me uh yes ma'am hahaha do you
remember the the two sisters from uh from Clone
Wars yeah I wonder if there's a connection
there you were heading to the outer rim
that is Caso Sereno the
former home Count Dooku yeah
yeah no he was a royal family with him being
dead Dooku's entire War chest is up for grabs
ah cool but there is still time to strike
before it's all gone too much of a risk
you want that war chest you
go after it Sid spin-off
date of the Empire's radar since kamino what
chance it now because the contents of just one
of those containers would be worth more than
all the jobs you pulled for me combined really
we're already free clearly you're not paying
attention to what's happening out there but I am
time before the Empire comes here exactly she
does have a valid point you want to really be
free and pull off this Heist and you'll have
the means to disappear the frick out of here
no way to the outer rim I have a feeling Hunter
and Omega will have some Strife in this season
hmm that feels appropriate but we can do better
things with Dooku's Fortune than hide Hunter
's looking for money
our lives are like this because of Omega oh you
know was the right thing to do but there are
others out there who need our help we've seen
what the Empire is doing throughout the Galaxy
we should be doing more I like this Echo yeah me
too and so Serrano is a really interesting place
it's Count Dooku and his dad had a
big falling out when he left for the
Jedi Order and kind of walked away from his
title and Dooku when he came back was able
to kind of you know live the life that uh its
father had dreamed of for him but at a cost
oh
these artists are not paid enough what happened to
it Imperial orbital bombardment same as old Camino
it appears that they are beginning to transport
the wall chest off-world our window of opportunity
is quickly closing I love the rebels stole some
of those in in Rebels for their little Fleet
I think they could do this
that is a risky ass mission
like at this point who's really even
opposing the empire there's nobody left
It's Gonna Hurt great shot oh man the priority is
items of high value like what anything shiny or
heavy is a start retrieve the remaining containers
from the palace stay on schedule oh foreign right
look at those credits it's gonna be like
a lightsaber or anything neat from Dooku's
collection I'd say that qualifies as high value
that the majority of Dooku's Fortune came from the
many worlds he controlled and exploited those
were corrupt people but that what we're doing
kids are too smart interesting
debate to be had you could use
the diversion about now on it
so Dooku had a lot of Fortune
huh yeah no Dooku's family comes from
money that's how we finance the war
originally when he left the Jedi Order Jedi
only really weren't that upset with him I think
probably because they gave them some money he made
some donations and stuff he was hoping he could
still have a good relationship what caused
the blast unknown Captain all systems went
normal prior to the explosion tried to pull three
secure your cargo and prepare to launch all scores
I love that they've started to strip away
some of the colors of the Clones
to take away their individuality
come on it's a hunter and Records go
through them yeah I was gonna say uh I
love that they're still just stunning them oh yeah
not too hard oh no we gotta
go where jump jump oh my God
do it we'll get to the marauder and recover you
uh oh they're about to be separated yeah that's
never a good sign are you sure this hitch will
lead into the ship if I am incorrect we will
instantly be sucked out and perish I am seldom
it's nice and ostentatious
oh trapdoor elevator
release the Escape pods
man they really want them containers
on classical Freighters are equipped
with re-entry thrusters we can
escape in a cargo container cargo
I love that I love how that container block yeah
we're getting out of here we're not going out
we're going down aha oh it's time to be clever
go hit it man here's me on an elevator
yikes Disney if you're watching
this big great new Tower of Terror
Tech is so much cooler than he
gets credit for yeah I agree
oh my God I love this
is going to be a problem all that fortune
foreign
ER they didn't did not mince a moment damn that
was cool yeah I'm I'm honestly so impressed all
right guys so we did a whole review for
episode one but then we realized oh wait
there's two episodes out so we're gonna watch
episode two right now yeah let's get to it
wow it's like meteors falling from the sky we
are descending at a rate of speed that is most
concerning don't worry increase should
engage soon if they don't we're all dead
no [__] Sherlock
Ah that's gotta hurt dick did you reach the Escape
pods yet not exactly we are using
an alternate mode of Transport my
calculations have us crashing towards the
upper Forest region of the planet crashing
leave you alone for five minutes
thank you for Flying Star Tours
Roger Roger
oh
no oh I was kidding when I said kill one of them
nerd
so no because some surprisingly
good writing so far this season
what do you see up there still haven't landed
uh that's funny that was wonderful like
picturesque shots yeah it's unlikely the
thieves who infiltrated the cargo ships survived
the crash I want confirmation redirect our top
side forces monitor all calm channels and bring
a shuttle yes sir Captain Wilkos the [__] huh
yeah right and that's sexy epaulette yeah Yum
Yum Yum we can't leave without the war chest
don't be cocky kid this is the path
to the dark side Omega is it greed
I wonder if there's any
survivors Jedi Survivor first
something about the aesthetic of Republic
gunships just does something for me my God
this is
I live here the name's Romar where's
the nearest place to take shelter
well it's a little hard to think
with her pointing that thing at me
well think with it I'm registering a
heat Source 200 meters west of here
's your domicile how did you take us there
divide the search and Recovery squads people
containers were released I want eyes on
all 50 copy that we only have 50 soldiers
how many explosives do you have nothing to do
any damage couple of smoke bombs smoke bombs for
record oh old separatist tanks now you're talking
he could do a lot of wreckage look at that you
know what I mean ah man you should quit your day
job he's gonna find a little wooden boy in there
Pinocchio a Star Wars story Troopers
could already be at the crash site
guess you're more like those
other clones than you think
oh I stay away from that cursed War chest if I
were you a cursed in war Chester he took from us
his own people there's enough in that
container for all of us I want none of it
let the Empire take it the sooner they're gone the
better and the same goes for you damn duker you've
done some serious damage we can still Scout
the sight to see if it's clear negative your
mission is to keep an eye on the old man Roger
you're gonna realize there's a new Mission at
hand Omega involves dealing with other people this
experience is really going to shape their values
thanks for the ride
please music
God you're just gonna stand there
no matters I'm keeping an eye on you
not much fun is it try that what
is it boy oh it's a kaleidoscope
uh jewels and no steal it it's an optical
illusion it's not treasure it's a toy
makes you happy and believe me that is worth
more than any Jewel except for an actual Jewel
yeah that's worth way more money like
a home that's not leveled by Hellfire
this here contains a fragment of my
people's history a separatist archive
fascinating we did exist before the war you
know I never thought of it like that racist
I love this like post-world War II like yeah
going to Berlin being like Oh yeah Germany
before they were there were just Nazis Germans
too we had lederhoses strudel a lot of culture
that one forget it wrecker
that Tank's not going anywhere
air support not approach air support man
they really can't take these two guys down
this kind of looks like the whenever
they cut to the Terminator future
yes
there goes not killing any clones
shot from the snow man
I love that one of them is
using a stun gun [__] up
your data has been restored you
did it you oh you saved my people
he was just here
no not his stuff no the old guy
stuff no I think she's going back
to the uh I think she still stalls the
old guys that's joking like what's wrong
is that her bad batch thing she's
a kleptomaniac yeah is that her
unique uh you won't get very far
in your condition I can manage
foreign oh my God him and
his people are gonna help
oh interesting and maybe they'll
give some of the treasure back
yeah this new Indiana Jones
movie is great I woke it up
cool murder murder
yeah the scent of his speeder I'm scanning
another container Dead Ahead stay alive
oh that was cool a little Order 66 when
they pull back in the um yes good references
LAPD
oh no he's got a broken leg too the bad legs
look I picked it full of the shiny stuff laughs
she's now become a precocious little child
great uh that's like Battlefront 2 right here
no no no no no take your way through it
I don't like this oh what the hell's going on
no you can't kill attack uh Echo is like the
most ungradable one uh Captain Wilco The
Intruders are retreating to the Eastern
Ridge reroute air support security teach Omega
lesson make Greg like Tech and then kill him
we're in position
those lasers can't take down those trees
I like that trees and video games
and trees and TV shows impenetrable
thank you oh I could feel that
ah come on come on come on oh good it's Oscar can
you imagine the off screen on ceremony is death
I don't feel good about it still
make sure to carry all the [__] oh my God
oh my gosh oh you gotta make a choice
it's like that scene in The Mummy yeah
it's gonna be a consequence yes it is I heard
what you said Hunter on the marauder you don't
have a normal life because of me oh no oh I
didn't realize that's why she was doing all that
oh that is so sad
all right all right
ace wake up
I heard Blaster fire I thought you might
need some help I love him and I was right
he'd fit right into the bad batch
I'd watch the spin off I will handle the ship
I'll grab the cable stun the ship freezes
come on Space Geppetto space pedo no no no Speedo
nicely done dude this is tax episode yeah
Ah that's badass
all right all right is that nice old
guy that helps you even got a flat
oh space pedal you did it
that would be our ride foreign
keep it what about you I'm a survivor
remember thanks Grandpa Joe that's
how Omega won the Chocolate Factory
for you Sid
and realize a mega was clocked in there yeah
I can't do it I tried doing a female one
oh my God what if he reports bad reports
oh you got a new toy see fun is everything
Greg I wanted to make things better for us I
know you all gave up everything because of me
good thing we did we might be fighting for the
Empire right now oh this is so touching we made
the right choice Omega I can't say touching I'd
do it all again oh they're about to be in trouble
you stated the would-be thieves you encountered
were the Rogue clones from experimental unit 99
however yet that is impossible and their squad
perished during the fall of De poker City ah they
don't realize that's how they've been free I had
visual confirmation on two of them they're alive
if Governor Tarkin were to learn of my misstep
then I would be at risk yeah which is why a
new report will be submitted one void of any
mention of Clone Force 99 that's the difference
between clones and humans I will not falsify
an official report they are about to die dude
foreign
I bet he's still falling oh man
Dave falloni what what uh what an experience
um is that how they're gonna phase out the
Clones by having every one of them one by one
brutally murdered by somebody's scared of Tarkin
laughs well well well that was a uh that was a
really good uh second episode yeah I was it was
action-packed uh we got a space Geppetto uh who
I'm glad I really thought they were gonna kill
him off I hope we see him again hope he gets his
own spin-off yeah I was in Riddell Romar Romar
Romar yeah okay you know what we should do for
YouTube yeah we should sort of combine what we
said oh for both for both episodes yeah yeah
just to make it a little bit easier easier for
you yeah for me personally actually to me and
and uh so here's uh the thoughts on the first
episode yeah playing I don't even remember that
nah dude the first episode is um like it was it
was awesome to see Omega come into her own yeah
um I like that like in Ezra in season one uh of
rebels where it was like oh this is gonna be rough
to have you as a protagonist uh it was really nice
season two you start seeing that growth change
um and it was really fun to like watch them grow
through the lens of the rest of the pad batch yeah
um and it was nice I feel like you know
as you're saying during the episode like
there was not a lot of utilization particularly
of tech and Echo um and the two of them really
stepped up and and this is what I was hoping
for when I saw the trailer yeah because
um like uh you know Echo especially is uh the
product of the evil that the Empire has done
and I've wanted to see more Echo because he
would have the most personal motive to want
to help you know and he kind of took a back seat
with the last season when the introduction of the
bad batch involved rescuing him so I thought
he'd be a more prominent character if it makes
sense for your first season you want to focus
you want to really flesh out here yeah the new
characters yeah and so I really love um that Echo
is becoming this motivating force I don't want
to do the thing I said I want to do let's just
combine what we're talking about into one episode
because yeah I think that what they did especially
with Omega was great as I didn't understand fully
like why she was so gung-ho and about like getting
that Treasure Chest did you pick up I didn't pick
up yeah well I said it you know it's like oh that
makes a lot of sense now it's interesting because
they've they've kind of set this stage for what
will be the conflict this season within the bad
batch with there being a sense of like it's either
we run or we fight and I've had it was interesting
to put Omega in that equation sure and I like
that they kind of set us up and then they reminded
us at the end that Omega is just a kid and her
perspective on this is coming from such a place
of innocence and a desire to fit in and to have a
family and the the real ramifications of what the
bad batch is deciding to do is just completely not
even on our radar yeah um I agree I agree I think
it's a great setup for them as a whole family
unit and I I did I guess I didn't register that
they all that the that people what's the name
of it it's not coming it was a specific city
called Serrano Sereno in in uh know where they
thought they died it is Camino what's the city
of Kansas
uh what's what's the the
the setup that oh yeah that's right they're
presumed dead right now yeah and and I think
it's it was especially Crosshair now that they're
alive yeah but it's in crosshairs interest to also
lie in this moment and it actually that that's
it there's a great point where it does set up
has Crosshair has the Chip And crosshairs
brain crossed hairs and yeah you know are
they beginning to question their allegiance
sure um because I always kind of wondered
how much of that was the chip and how much of
that was Crosshair seems like it's mainly him
I feel like it the the at least a part of him um
you know uh it's definitely really interesting to
see how humans as they enter Imperial ranks
are like it kind of shows the demise of the
Empire really of like oh well I'm scared of the
consequence of fader forth Force choking me out
in a meeting so I'm gonna not tell the truth
yeah um yeah that guy's gonna get Force jokes
uh Wilco is great though um I really I thought
that was like a I was hoping we'd see more of
him but I'm like we thought we're gonna get
Cody yeah well I think that's what's going to
be really fun about Echo this season right
like he is the only character that I think
from the perspective of like your average clone
during the Clone Wars will be able to really
like the weight of leaving the fight I think
is going to hit him harder than everybody else
um and also needing to go directly against
the other clones um you know so it'll it'll
be interesting to see what what happens um
you know I'm I'm curious as to this kind
of setup of this the the new character what
was her name at the at the top Wanda Sykes
good brain um you know I wonder if that's
going to be connected to any of our other
you know um yeah and it was it was nice that they
they seem aware that you finished that sentence
it's a great finisher a good button on that did
I wrapped it with a bow what was the the name of
um oh yeah I wonder if that's going
to be connected um yeah yeah but uh
so I wonder if that's gonna
be connected to anything
no I I definitely uh as it pertains to fee
I'm curious if if she's gonna be connected
to some Rebel elements or you know if
maybe that's how we're gonna reconnect
to the Galaxy at large in terms of you
know I mean it's there is no Rebellion
per se at this point like everything's
in its infancy and I feel like that's a
I'm excited to see what that looks like you
know what was neat was like when we did the
we felt the reaction for the first episode and
we're putting one and two in the same episode
but you were doing a lot of uh you're pointing
out a lot of like the history of of um Serrano
no God yeah yeah the Dooku yeah yeah yeah I
remember feet but Dooku is a hard pool for me
but uh with uh Dooku and and um and then it was
crazy to see how much that history did factor
in so much with this Romar character yeah and uh
explaining his people and and how and it really is
like he is like a Hitler kind of kid is it is
it was like a citizen in Berlin after the war
who's just like really struggling yeah to I mean
how do you separate the evil and the selfishness
of an individual from an entire people you know
and uh you know and you see the reality of it
um and at the end of the day the thing that he
was most concerned about it wasn't the treasure
wasn't the money it was preserving their culture
their past exactly and their identity separate
of ironically the separatists um you know so
yeah I thought that was really well done and
I thought Serrano was such an interesting it was
an interesting choice um because I think something
that will be fun throughout bad batch is to watch
these characters slowly and surely realize that
even when they were in the Republic that doesn't
necessarily mean they were the good guys yeah
um and I feel like that's such a great you know
I love George Lucas but like Star Wars very good
very evil like it was it was always very clear who
is what um and something that was really wonderful
about the Clone Wars is it really explored all
the gray and Andor too and and or especially Andor
um that's a great Point yeah um yeah so
I mean it was a it was a a great start
um you know I sometimes with the show I feel like
it was made specifically for Dave filoni like
it's his you know like like he watches it a couple
thousand times to keep the views and stuff up
but like um but I wish more people watched it and
enjoyed it because I'm beginning to see the thread
between this to the new Ahsoka series to Andor
to Mandalorian oh what the the one of the show
Runners recently came out and said like no there's
going to be some very clear connections I mean
they already had like Fenix Shan in the last one
oh yeah but there's gonna be some uh it's gonna
be much clearer the connection to Mandalorian um
this season so I think omega's particular cloning
existence is gonna be connected to grogu and a lot
of what because they're more than likely yeah well
the planet that we saw at the end of of the last
season where the Survivor from Camino was brought
um I mean that's the the cloning facility were
like it all got started with with grogu and all
that stuff so but damn there's some good [__] in
here yeah I am I'm I do prefer this show when it's
more a serious and more and darkest personally
like I love all the nighttime sequences I think
they executed the action great the music is just
as exciting as ever and I did buy like they pulled
a gun punch here and just randomly killed off Tech
you know I was I was actually I thought mistakes
could could be that high which is a great a
great place I mean I think similar to Rebels
I think they want the show to grow with the
audience you know I mean every time I I watch
Star Wars animated series you know I I feel like
they give they give us older fans just enough to
like hold on while the show gets darker and
grittier sure but they do let their audience
grow with them and like I love that that's
one of my favorite parts of Star Wars is that
no matter what your entry point is you know if
a kid's at like nine or ten like this is epic
you know this is a great way to get into it and
I felt that way with Rebels too where like first
season I was like oh boy this is rough um you know
but by like season end of season two I was like
this is a show for me too and um the only one I
haven't felt that way about was resistance and
I think they wanted it that way yeah um I also
just couldn't get past that animation um which
like speaking of I I just like I feel like they've
hit their stride like this is stunning animation
and they've upgraded I mean I I felt like last
season the first and last two episodes were were
at its prime like it feels like they really threw
down for their first and last couple and then this
one for the first two at least because the last
season they had a like a really long Premiere
didn't they it was like a 40-minute episode yeah
it was a they did exactly the same thing here yeah
we're gonna put in two episodes instead I still
I still have not recovered from them not doing
anything with Freddie Prince Junior's voice that's
young Kane and jarus as like why is there a grown
man speaking in this 12 year old uh but you know
but I I thought the you know the darker they get
the better the series is yeah I mean just like
watching Caminos think was just like well even
like that menacing ending that they had here it
was uh like I I love that tone a lot and I love
like this sneak and I think they do a great job
with their perspectives and their shots uh it's
it's really well calculated so yeah yeah it's it's
a I think my biggest compliment to them is there's
such nice subtle homages to both prior Star Wars
films but other just like really gritty like there
was a few uh moments in there where the soundtrack
and the shots lined up with like Children of Men
which I was like like what the hell are Star
Wars animators doing like using children of
men as their storyboard um but like it works
and I think it's Star Wars at its best yeah so
all right well we had a really good premiere
thank you Michael for being here and bringing
all the Star Wars knowledge oh of course can't
wait to sit here with you 14 more times 14 times
oh they like me they really like me and and
thank you for all the fan mail that I got uh
that was so sweet of you guys I'm glad you liked
my yoda voice I liked my voice didn't you yeah
let's not oh let's not do that overdo it you
know all right Jack Sparrow was Charming the
first three times then it started to get old you
know yeah well that's what my mom said about me
all right guys May the force be with
you and the force me to leave a like
foreign